[Music]
hi there uh the voice fam we are here
closing out season 12 with the winner
winner winner chicken dinner chris blue
is here welcome thank you thank you
sophie i'm glad to be here uh thanks so
much for coming in i understand you have
not slept yet at all you know
call time yesterday was like 7 30 a.m
and after they said chris blue was a
winner how do you go to sleep after that
right no you don't yeah i'm still here
i'm still
vibing off of that energy man you have
any like caffeine going through or is
this just a natural high today well it
was a natural high for a good while but
then i had a latte earlier with some
espresso in it so it kind of helped me
out yeah you need one um let's show
everybody you brought a little souvenir
today now it's not your trophy but it's
i it's almost better than this right i
had to keep the trophy in the in the
case in the closet but this right here
this is like
baby number two right now man um yeah
gosh look at this so explain the
significance of this belt to me so i am
a die-hard
wwe fan so if you want to know something
about chris blue that you can't tell by
looking at me it's this right here okay
i'm a kid at heart i love the wwe i'm a
huge wrestling fan always been that way
my brothers and i grew up watching
wrestlemania and um we've always wanted
to like go to wrestlemania and like be a
part of it and so i felt like well i've
always wanted a belt like a real replica
and um you know we won the voice i said
i think this is the appropriate time to
whip it out man yeah absolutely and you
this isn't the only one you bought
either it isn't you know i decided you
know for the top four i wanted to gift a
wrestling belt to all of the contestants
so i bought everyone a championship belt
to commemorate the moment and wish them
well in life and let everyone know that
no matter what we're all champions i
love it that is so sweet okay so let's
get get into the nitty-gritty of last
night take me back through the moment
when carson announced your name what was
going through your head oh my gosh man
um everything i thought about my entire
process it all started back in june of
last year
i stood in a line of about seven to ten
thousand people
open calls and um almost didn't go
because i was afraid i wouldn't get
picked but my fiance talked me into to
going and i did
but i felt like hey if we don't get
picked i just won't say i i came here
this never happened we can just pretend
like this never happened so um we got we
got chosen and a call back and another
call back another call back
next thing you know
carson's saying and the winner of the
voice
is chris blue and um wow so i thought
about all of that and i thought about
every person that has ever supported
chris blue
and um
all that i've stood for on this journey
i thought about my family i wanted the
confetti to fall on them and they were
there for that moment
and i wanted it so bad for my amazing
coach alicia keys i mean she has been
beyond amazing and alicia is thrilled to
say the least she was pumped man she was
like she was getting it oh yeah oh yeah
she yeah i mean it was it was pretty
clear she's been talking um you know
we've been covering the show all season
as i told you and uh alicia it seems
every week she's like i'm gonna beat
blake i'm gonna beat blake
and i think it was uh
maybe more exciting for her to be able
to take home the trophy last night um
what are some like last minute words of
wisdom that she maybe gave you last
night or and have you made any plans to
stay in touch well yeah absolutely you
know one of the things that i gravitate
to you know with her is her spirit and i
wanted a coach
um that i felt like actually cared about
chris
and not just a competition and not just
winning but actually cared about me and
my career you know post this show and
she she accomplished that and um
i could tell she really cares about
chris and i care about alicia and that's
when you really make magic
you know because when you when you want
something not only for yourself but also
for someone else i think that kind of
helps
uh the the motivational aspect of of
what you do and and
i don't know man she's more than a coach
she's really a friend i love that yeah i
love that well i would love to see you
two get in the studio together yeah that
would be awesome
yeah that would be awesome that would be
so awesome no plans yet though it's
still early right you're still figuring
out how the whole album process is gonna
go absolutely we're still working on on
all of that right now but i can tell you
we are ready to get to work
and um i'm excited and i can't wait yeah
uh to go back to the moment a little bit
you standing there with lauren who
you've gone through this whole
experience with um tell me about
that moment sharing it with her and what
you guys said to each other
you know um
first of all i want to say lauren duskey
is a phenomenal human being and singer
the one of the most sweetest kindest uh
purest hearts i think i've ever met in
my life um
and that's my sister and and i love her
to pieces
um you know we just hugged each other
and said you know i love you you know
she wished me well and i wished her well
and she's going to do big things in
country music i really feel like she has
become
you know like a country queen yeah you
know the country she's like number one
every week you know so um she's gonna do
very well and i'm proud of her
so now how did you celebrate after the
show after the confetti falls and the
cameras cut what were you doing
well uh i went to try to retrieve my
belt
i wanted i wanted my tight i wanted to
won the championship first things first
need the belt i need the belt man i need
i need the belt um and it's just a lot
of
uh meditating and reflecting you know we
just thought about you know everything
and i just you know talked to my coach
you know loved on her and we just kind
of had a few moments there you know to
just kind of reflect you know briefly
she had to catch a flight so we didn't
have a whole lot of time but
and just a lot of reflecting yeah yeah
that's incredible that's so special
um
you also shared another emotional moment
in the finale with usher oh gosh
whoo
tell me about that and what was going
through your mind
you know first of all i want to say
usher's phenomenal he really is a
special guy man
um he and alicia you know they've been
in the music industry for so long not
because not only rather i i should say
not only because they're so gifted but
because of their characters
and i've always been taught never allow
your gift to take you where your
character won't keep you
and their characters have kept them in
some pretty remarkable places um
usher was the first guy that inspired me
to dance wow
i can see it i like it he did he did let
it burn was a music video i saw back in
the sixth grade and when he like did the
glide across the stage and like he had
the mic stand dragging it i was like i
want to do that that's pretty
awesome
and so um
to to have that go full circle and to
share a stage with him was was pretty
mind-blowing that's incredible
incredible
i got my phone out because i feel it
buzzing which means you guys at home are
sending in lots of great questions and
comments i just want to read a couple to
you um edna says congratulations thank
you um edward wants to know what was it
like to work with alicia yo alicia is
seriously amazing um
it's like working with family you know
when when you walk in the room and she
smiles you just feels like it just feels
like everything's gonna be better like
your whole day is now better you walk in
like i hate my life i hate the day you
see alicia smile
it's gonna be okay everything's gonna be
okay you know that's what she possesses
so that's what it's like working with
her man it's just a breath of fresh air
i love it uh i gotta read you this
comment from christina she says congrats
chris and always listen to your fiance
she's a smart woman yes she
is
i've learned that um i didn't need money
on a college degree i just need to learn
two words yes dear
yes you that is good good advice um so
how was it sharing that moment with your
fiance and any plans to
make your wife soon yeah yeah we're
gonna do it in july oh good we've always
had planned for that you know she called
me about a month ago in tears because we
didn't have enough money to decorate the
church
or have wedding cars and
i said to her last night now babe you
can get whatever you want wow
you can have it so that's so special
uh any of your voice fam coming to the
wedding now like will alicia be there
i would love for alicia to be there yeah
you know that would be super special i
know she's kind of busy right now but
i'm going to ask don't hurt those
invites absolutely yeah absolutely um
christina also after she said that very
wise thing about your fiance she wanted
to know what genre of music do you see
yourself recording and performing wow
you know that's a great question um
because we did so much on the show
i would say
the genre
of hope
because that's the business i'm in i'm
into
you know releasing hope into the world
um our world is
kind of struggling in that department
right now and that's what i want to feed
i believe that music is the one
language that we all can relate to and
so i want to make sure that hope is fed
through that and love and joy so that's
what i'm going to do i love that now we
are still kind of waiting on a true
superstar to come out of this show so
what is it now going through this
experience what are you going to do
differently than maybe winners in the
past have you thought about how you want
to you know make it to the next level
i have you know and i think about i've
been thinking about that actually um
here recently it's a great question um
i think the thing is to
not stay planted too long
here
because the fact of the matter is we won
the voice
last night
and that was the goal to win the voice
what's the next goal
and let's attack that just like we
attacked this one
and um
with that and a lot of grace from god
and a lot of praying i think
i'm praying that that we'll be able to
accomplish that i'd love to to be that
breakout star and come back to the voice
and say thank you once again thank you
america for what you created i love that
i would love that what is the next goal
um
more gold
more gold yes if you know if are you
reading me i'm feeling it more gold
uh-huh
i love it
okay well we are so excited to see more
of what's to come for you i'm going to
check one more time for fan questions if
you have any last-minute questions guys
get them in right now um
heather says you are so talented you
brought so much joy into my home oh wow
bless you
i mean what does it mean to you to get
those kind of responses from the fans
you know um
it's
so heartwarming it really is it's so
refreshing because that's at the end of
the day that's all you really want to do
you want to inspire people you want to
motivate someone you want to instill
hope and just let everyone know man hey
everything's gonna be okay yeah and to
know that that's working that's that's a
blessing the genre of hope uh mindy says
i know it's early but when you start
your tour will you do a concert in
knoxville oh man knoxville's that's
that's where we're gonna we'll either
start in knoxville
finish in knoxville yeah we'll start and
finish
there you go i love it what else are you
most looking forward to in the next year
i mean this is gonna be a whirlwind for
you i think you know um i feel like the
voice has opened up so many
doors and lanes and opportunities
i look forward to really establishing my
footprint in the music industry as well
as the entertainment world completely
not et entertainment tonight you're
doing a fabulous job i can't i will
never be able to take your job
but i would love to like get into acting
and movies wow i'd love to be on the big
screen those are some of my
uh goals on the bucket list so that's
great be pretty cool you're on your way
and i'm excited to hear all about your
wedding yeah it's going to be fun man
yeah i did zero planning my fancy did it
all
proud of you you had a great excuse yeah
absolutely
thank you so much for being here chris
congratulations on everything thank you
guys so much for watching for any and
all the voice coverage keep checking
back to etonline.com
we have you know full recaps from last
night interviews with the coaches
contestants all that good stuff and
we'll see you next season
[Music]
you